[Music]
in porn patrol news paw patrol paw
patrol what are you eating yeah supposed
to be mine even submitted by an awesome
80s porn star it seems it's very weird
yeah different perspective of sensual
buildup huh you guys remember the first
porno yeah let's - girls - ah Debbie
Does Dallas the movie it was eighties
eighties eighties really vintage porn
cuz it's weird I feel like I'm watching
grandparents now cuz like now that
that's what I'm saying because like you
look at them and they're beautiful but
then like now you imagine them now oh
yeah so it looks like grandparents
[ __ ] you depends on how old I
understand
I'm with TIFF cuz if it's like 80s or
90s or whatever then I'm like oh it
brings me back to the childhood days
when I first watched porn because that's
the tapes and like stuff that I saw I
feel like any sport was a little more
authentic offense like that's the thing
that was so fake yeah yeah it was so
show me the bodies look different Debbie
Does Dallas storyline was like could
grow those trapped in a farmhouse that
make sense and just protecting our
animals it's so for some reason someone
came and [ __ ] her
really that's pretty was like the guy's
like a football player that might be the
second subplot I think he came before
that subpart is that a portal yeah dubby
dubby does dallas it was like the first
one me and all my homies watching you
remember that we're like two old when
you were ten no how old are you and we
do this I mean are what grade are you 10
for fourth or fifth grade is when we
started looking at playboys and finding
out that that should exist
I saw my first porn mag at like eight
years old
I know because they just smell this room
didn't y'all know now it's like if you
got phones and it's a loaded [ __ ]
weapon man left hand our right hands
give dabs with which hand yeah that's
true too cuz when you're gonna Jill you
remember Jill you know like Jay uh yeah
kicking it with Jill that see if it
works
alright anyway a lot of the kid I yeah
we're getting gay or something that's in
the gate [ __ ] for a smart kids group oh
yeah gifted and talented education oh
yeah that's what gates dance you're gay
oh yeah Yugoslavia once and then they
split up I'll tell you smart not that
he's smart I remember the gate program
smart far down you know why is because
you had friends that's [ __ ] I'm smart
and I had Jill okay the gate program is
like magnet school in the public school
but not quite magnets yeah yeah same
with like the International
Baccalaureate program in like high
schools yeah yeah it was like Advanced
Placement AP IB International
Baccalaureate AP because I had a couple
nice no AP - I don't know what IB is by
that time me was just a gang
[Laughter]
I miss a game on the [ __ ] um I'll be
baby alright we gotta get the articles
China is offering its citizens almost
90,000 dollars to report porn to the
police
so they could see it for themselves and
investigate you know why this chat is
probably nothing that happen at unique
Aloha China what happened will happen at
you home okay so like the Chinese
details because you go there a lot okay
so in this in Beijing I believe it's in
this shopping area called Thai food is
pretty much like their main heart of
fashion district really high-end stuff
is stuff like that one side of it has a
unique low and then I believe if the
story is correct I believe when it
happened there recently maybe like a
month or two ago was a couple was having
sex in the dressing room right and like
it's a chick who's just like butt naked
I saw like 10 seconds of it it was great
and she's just like a kid against the
wall maybe holding in the phone or maybe
the guy behind fully clothed this asian
dude why is he fully clothed I don't
know
he's like fully clothed by doing it from
the back of recording something like
that right apparently they like break up
in a non amicable way and then he posted
this video online and he goes he'll
revenge holy [ __ ] viral like it's on
like TV news like everyone has you
millions like wow yeah it's terrible
and then so I saw it 10 times and I was
[ __ ] pissed every point is oh it was
so big the thing that even when I was
walking around that area because that's
when the nude Doug Joe shut up since I
was walking in that area people would
come up to me and like interview me in
front of that uniquely yeah trying to
ask about like what it happened it was
like that big of news so is like crazy
but that's what I think is connected to
this why is not with porno how do they
why is it connected well because they
were having sex inside things song I'm
guessing more the idea that if like you
catch somebody maybe videotaping
somebody doing that then there's a
possibility that it could go into that
direction so just no sex on video at all
is not the new policy um I wonder if
porn is illegal in China I've never seen
Chinese ports me neither
I mean I haven't seen Chinese produced
porn but
are you way through the credits once he
finishes one well there are a couple of
Chinese guys as ApS on the last one
there are some Chinese amateur people
that like to record having sex with
their partners on the camera and I
noticed that's perfect but I noticed
that they're wearing masks or they blare
out their faces yeah so all types of
porn is illegal but the all them are the
illegal everything yeah that's why so
they record like I don't know if they're
home videos for for themselves or like
whatever but I fell into this whole area
of Chinese porn because I was like hold
up this is not the Japanese porn that
I'm used to
nor is it Southeast Asian what kind of
porn is this and I started clicking
around there's there's some there's some
Chinese guys [ __ ] hookers you're so
there's some there's some Chinese
couples romantically [ __ ] sure
there's some Chinese girls just
performing for their book there's just
like wow I just thought Chinese people
didn't have sex
porno you so [ __ ] logical he's
clicking on he's like whoa wait a minute
this is interesting stuff it reminds me
of me walking up to an old bed of the
street and asking for directions and I
get this answer excuse me sir do you
know where the bathroom is well let me
tell you something real quick government
body that's in charge with cleaning of
China's web and so it's called the
national office against pornographic and
illegal public office yeah pornographic
oh yeah and so this whole campaign thing
it's called clean up the pornographic
kama strike the illegal and so they're
offering their I know they're off
they're offering a hefty cash sum of six
hundred thousand yuan which is about
ninety
u.s. dollars that's our grip which is a
lot because the annual salary of an
employee in urban China is about
seventy-five thousand yuan Wow you know
what they need to do is hire some you
know filmmakers to go out there to teach
them how to [ __ ] record it right with
angles no it's illegal I know but like
what's illegal to me is how poorly it's
shot okay cuz I'm like you guys never
watched it and then you can't get the
right angle so you you you you try to
look at it like like it's a window and
it like it's gonna [ __ ] change and
I'm like [ __ ] dude you can't look at it
that way you've got the worst blood so
yeah important was for me it was when
there's a really good part and all the
sudden switched to a guy's face the guys
they usually do right before he busts ya
what it's like surprise they're gonna
come on my face and it's a man's face oh
maybe they want that to not make you [ __ ]
so you could keep watching other videos
is that what that is because it it's
like what it is is like there's there's
definitely guys that get turned down
there's probably guys that get turned on
watching a man being turned on because
they think he's turned on like their
target he's gotta be a guy because
there's a reason why they do it
oh use a part or not and then it cuts to
the guy's face like
you're talking about those we're gonna
seek this nut bro and any cuts to attach
to the girl's face and in the [ __ ]
[ __ ] goes on her face it's the same [ __ ]
when you play a pacman game and then the
[ __ ] face comes out you start screaming
because it's a yeah you're solving the
pac-man puzzle yeah the food all sudden
the ring face but not since your
intention is to progress the narrative I
don't think it's for a nut sync or two
like a nut sync you right but I mean
that's just tell me you don't know wait
education man they just learned these
big gates myself okay I said good
education you telling me you haven't
seen that though I've seen they do this
this is basic porn trollin [ __ ]
filmmaking they always do this on you
how much you want to bet there's a
cross-dressing this right now taking
notes
who put men come face before coming no
sinking they don't say not Chinese Falls
don't take notes you ever seen their
movies it's all [ __ ] kung fu movies
like the best no those actually have
good stories the new ones that are
coming out man you know what I've been
watching that's pretty Chinese like
they're little they have like a vine
kind of [ __ ] now yeah it's [ __ ] wild
man tik-tok yeah yeah it's similar to
vine it's like short second videos have
you seen the that musically yeah yeah
it's similar to that so it's like a
really short inner like term video and
it's oftentimes paired with some sort of
music or has some sort of repetitive
like essence to it yeah alright so China
they do take porn so seriously that
there was this one author who recently
was sentenced to 10 and a half years in
prison for producing and selling
pornographic materials yeah after her
gay
erotic novel called occupy went viral
that's funny how they take porn so
serious when there's brothels all over
the [ __ ] place
yeah not that I went to it or anything
like that
[Laughter]
perfect time to cut yeah I went to know
I went to wonder please Ida [ __ ] item
[ __ ] girl though remember I told you
guys yeah one to one
not that I [ __ ] one or anything I told
you guys this story yeah yeah because my
friends they love buying hookers all the
time and then like they would tell me
all the spots they're like that would
they're like you think that's a
barbershop but when they got the
spinning wheel II think big you're go in
the back you can't blow jobs they're
like that one this is like you want to
go to the spa and I'm like all right and
then I go to the spa and then I go
downstairs and there's like a team of
little boys it's not pedophilia they
don't think that way they're servants
and then they help you get like this and
then they fold your clothes and stuff
they help you get undressed slaves
indentured servants yeah they're like
are there like a hotel [ __ ] Budapest
like they're like they're like they're
like they're like oh sir can i [ __ ]
fold your clothes sir and I'm like man
that's making me uncomfortable and I
look over and there's like businessman
that get their coats all like folded and
they're like I'm a [ __ ] King and I'm
like don't touch me boy I'll do it
myself
and you slap them there's like there's
like a buffet they're trying a red flag
counter in the corner of the video or
anything no there's bats
there's buffets there's all kinds of
money count some [ __ ] money gets like I
pay for that there's a regular spa with
little boys that fold your clothes yeah
but there's also there's a whorehouse in
there they pulled me I was like I
thought were going to a spa and then I
went into a room and it's like a hotel
room with the big-screen TV and this guy
pulls in girls you like her you like big
boobs and all that [ __ ] and I'm all I've
what the [ __ ] and my friend comes over
he's like I don't want to lose my
virginity to a hooker
yeah and I'm all like yeah this is kind
of weird man
and then like milder friend he's a
whoremonger so he's just he's a [ __ ]
regular dude he's doing his thing and I
was like alright what do you want to do
it use this go get some massages so we
go upstairs and we're like getting
massages and in like I guess like
there's some real massage no like a real
like it's a spa like it's like national
service yeah you get yeah and it's all
getting massages and it like I guess in
Mandarin they were telling them like you
could have [ __ ] her in the ass you
could have done this and bad and then
I'm like damn that's crazy
I speak to you getting massage and they
can try to like touch you and then
you're told no like that mean where the
girls are hot and then it's this asian
place stop I have to study
another boy keep on trying folded
clothes you keep kicking in his ass and
that was yeah and I was like this is
[ __ ] wild that's what they that's
what they need to crack down on not
[ __ ] porn
yeah massages
[Music]
[Music]